i was always i can't you shouldn't
don't do this
you know it's impossible
it's too challenging it's too difficult
they're saying that i can't before i
even attempt to try
that's that's not the way to live
i was up doing a wheelie on the freeway
i went to try to get away from the
police officer
a car emerged into my lane and i hit the
center divider
this decision to do that actually cost
me
the ability to ever walk again
when i got out of the hospital after my
injury i realized everybody that was in
a wheelchair was either wearing these
elastic waistband pants or getting by
wearing sweatpants and that's when i
realized hey these guys need help
we're in our los angeles california
factory where we manufacture and make my
ability jeans
normal jeans don't fit us we can't
access back pockets
and buttons and rivets can cause
pressure source for people in
wheelchairs so we don't have no rear
pockets smooth surface in the back
we take all things into consideration
you know the durability of them our belt
loops being stronger so when you pull
your pants up by the belt loop they
don't break
but in a way that they don't stand out
they look as great as every other jean
that's on the market
they told me i would never walk
again i was like well i will be able to
ride motorcycles right
they said my life doing that was over
and that was the reason why i said it
wasn't and i'm going to build something
that i am going to be able to ride again
we ride for that freedom you know
i look at the road i look at what's
around me i feel the throttle
and i ride i don't look over and say
oh there's my wheelchair i got to get
back to that when i'm no for the moment
i'm riding and it's freedom ain't
nothing that can compare to that